leute herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video in diesem wunderschönen weit
panorama ihr habt zum titel gelesen
lagerfeuer mcinnis klingt doch
unglaublich geil ich habe auch unfassbar
bock das ganze zu machen gehört aber mal
raus dass meine rein in die natur und
dieses ganz besondere erlebnis mit euch
teilen was ganz ganz wichtig ist man
darf natürlich nicht überall im wald
einfach so ein feuer machen da der
förster probleme das auch ziemlich
unsicher wir sind ja zu gast bei der
event location solch partei wir haben
uns eingeladen wir schlagen uns ein
bisschen feuerholz von ihnen und dann
machen wir uns auf die suche nach dem
perfekten spot auch hier ok glück gehabt
dass sie hier doch was haben wir waren
ganz optimistisch ich dachte mir sollte
kommen
finden schon holzhütte feuermachen
genommen da so ein paar kleine
anzündholz hier mit gott aber so safer
variante ich taste mich ja jetzt heran
dann machen wir es mal auf die suche ich
persönlich ich bin in einem ländlichen
umfeld aufgewachsen und ich liebe so
diese naturgeräusche man hört euch das
einfach an so ich glaube wir benutzen
auch gar keine musik in diesem video und
das wird einfach ein weibliches video
und das wird richtig gut
so was sagt mitbewerb werden hier vorne
wo man so verliert man hier sieht so
eine ebene errichtete direkt schön am
wasser und auch die steine auf die wir
zurückgreifen können und ich finde es
wunderschön hier ja also dann hier bauen
wir uns auch
probiert zuallererst einmal jetzt unsere
feuerstelle vorzubereiten weil damit
steht und fällt auf diesem platz hier
wirklich verwenden professionell wie ich
bin mache ich das laufwerk man das wird
eh nicht brennen das hat volker geregnet
in den letzten tagen deshalb ist auch
ein guter zeitpunkt um dieses video zu
drehen so wenn es nicht geregnet hat
sollte man erst recht kein feuer im wald
machen damit das feuer nicht übergreift
lege ich darauf jetzt erstmal so einen
kleinen rahmen aus stein
das sieht ja schon wild aus jetzt
präsent ich hab das perfekte schuhwerk
an
ich stehe das bereits schon mal bereit
dann machen wir das feuer an und ganz
kurz eine sache wir haben jetzt an
feuerholz dem feuer holt das geht alles
noch viel primitiver aber bisher aber
langsam an wenn ihr daran jetzt spaß
haben können wir gerne malen wir machen
wo wir das ganze machen ohne auf
jegliche technologien zurückzugreifen
also ich würde es zumindest versuchen
all right dann probiere ich jetzt mal
das feuer an zu machen ich berufe mich
jetzt auf mein beschränkt ist wissen wir
aus fritz meinecke videos habe ich
glaube als anzünder kann man relativ gut
so holzschnitzer benutzen also anzünder
der anzünder quasi sich wer zumindest
das ganz wo wir mit nur einem
streichholz an zu machen
da aber jetzt kann man es langsam wagen
wir haben jetzt schön haufen holz dann
legen wir so ein bisschen darf außen rum
dass er dann auch direkt feuer fangen
kann glaube dann kann ich auch schon
meinen schotten aber das sagen die
meisten survival experte wir reden auch
sowie der reise
seid ihr bereit leute
mein einziger versuch nie warum wir das
als erstes machen das auch ganz klar das
feuer braucht gleich eine weile gerade
wenn wir die großen holzscheite
drauflegen bin aber zuversichtlich dass
wir den teil vom feuer zumindest gut
hinbekommen wie man damit umgeht also
wie man mit dieser glut und so weiter
und sport kocht das natürlich was ganz
anderes
ja war doch wirklich klar dass es direkt
mit dem ersten versuch
so mancher ist doch ein bisschen angst
tragen aber das kriegen wir hin
das wichtiger step auch nur ein bisschen
umstrukturiert das feuer jetzt brennt's
sehr schön wir fügen aber jetzt auch
schon die großen holzscheite hinzu damit
das ganze auch mit anderen
und es fällt wahrscheinlich genau drei
sekunden so aber dass sie doch meist ja
ich würde sagen werde das ganze hier
durchziehen erkunden wir ein bisschen
die natur lassen das auf uns wirken und
halten das natürlich auch mit der kamera
die das harz oben aus
vorher ist ein bisschen zusammengeführt
wir legen jetzt die holzscheite einmal
hin wir gleich einen schönen fläche
haben hier vielleicht um eine ecke schon
werbung gelesen das video wird wieder
unterstützt funktionell ich habe schon
mal diese zehn kilogramm pasta im
käselaibe gemacht und auch heute waren
sie so nett mich wieder zu unterstützen
die habe ich sechs verschiedene
französische käse liegen warum ich genau
die ausgewählt habt erzähle ich euch
jetzt zunächst haben wir einen
kommentare sehr auf der mindestens 36
monate gereift ist und dadurch einen
kräftigen würzigen geschmack hat dann
haben wir ein minarett der seine farbe
durch blüten samen erhält und ebenfalls
schön kräftig ist das hier ist ein buch
von mir wirklich sehr fruchtig riecht
und ich bin gespannt wie er sich machen
gewinnen schon fair bedeutet übrigens
dass der käse auf den bauernhof in
handarbeit hergestellt wurde also fernab
von industrieller massenproduktion und
diese liebe die da im käse steckt wird
man mit sicherheit auch in unserem
gericht schmecken und die letzten drei
käse sind ein stalev dem je ein tor und
ein abo doors fan alles in allem gibt
das glaube ich die perfekte balance und
ist beim besten willen kein normales
mckenzies auch abseits der tatsache dass
bis auf blut auf feuer kochen aber ich
muss diesen käse jetzt erst mal reiben
brauchen ungefähr 500 gramm geriebenen
käse und das machen wir jetzt und damit
wir zum reiben platz haben es geht jetzt
endlich los ihr könnt euch vorstellen
dass feuer braucht eine weile geben wir
unsere makkaroni einmal in unseren top
und bedecken die gerade so mit wasser so
dann stellen wir unseren top leuten
natürlich ein gusseiserner sein oder so
die rag wasser drauf
bisschen mehr muss es doch sein dass die
makkaroni gerade so bedeckt sind es gibt
ja die grundregel 100 gramm nudeln ein
liter wasser in dem fall nicht wir
wollen nämlich dass das gesamte wasser
verkocht und dass wir wirklich die
stärke die die nudeln abgeben an das
nudelwasser in der soße behalten also
wir machen nur millimeter über die linie
wo die nudeln gefüllt sind früheren das
ganze dann kontinuierlich um und so
entsteht dann eine cremige soße werden
alles gut läuft
[Applaus]
das sieht schon richtig aus das sieht
schon so aus ein bisschen schon stärker
abgegangen es gibt richtig stärker ab
von iwakuni hier arbeiten auch direkt
das dauert auch nur sechs minuten auf
wenn sich überlegen eine herdplatte denn
keine ahnung wie lange das bei uns
dauert
das schwierigste aufgabe jetzt für dich
wird es glaube ich seinen 500 gramm käse
abzuschätzen wie abzuschätzen und dabei
die ganze hätten die hocke zu sein denn
ein alter mann
käse nummer eins
was herzlich willkommen das sind so
weit ich bin der king schätze ich glaub
mir das nicht treffe man alles auf den
punkt genau das geht jetzt alles hier
stark aufschlagende tatsächlich schlag
auf schlag also hier kocht langsam das
heißt wir müssen umrühren problemen
wissen dagegen zu pusten dass sie etwas
sehen können
bringt gar nichts so wie jetzt ist da
wir freuen uns dass sie da ist aber wir
müssen jetzt aufpassen dass das ganze
auch nicht zu schnell kocht und zu sehr
abgebaut es geht schon rund da muss man
sagen auf jeden fall wir geben dazu auch
noch ein bisschen salz gute prise waren
jetzt knapp 500 gramm nudeln die wir der
hand wo sieht auf jeden fall raus die
maroni ziehen durch werden fertig und es
hat wirklich was das war ich schon immer
mal machen es gibt ja diesen einen tick
tock kanal mainboards und die kochen
immer die geilsten sachen so im wald und
ich hatte schon wirklich die ganze zeit
lust auch mal so diese erfahrung zu
machen sondern das jetzt zu tun ist
ultra da ist ein bild für die götter es
fühlt sich auch einfach richtig
angeeignet habe wirklich keine ahnung ob
es am ende auch ein gutes produkt gibt
also ob das gericht gut wird aber es
macht ja schon so viel spaß fühlt sich
so richtig an und du sitzt genau wir
brauchen hier
so leute es ist vollbracht mein oberarm
tut weh aber sechs verschiedene käse
wunderschön geschrieben es ist
unglaublich viel dass uns alles fertig
machen ist zu schlagen wenn wir
durchgehend das ist unser signal dass
wir die nudeln runterziehen seht euch
das an durch die stärke die sich auf die
nudeln gelebt hat ist schon fast wie
eine eigene soße und das wasser so ich
komplett weg innerhalb von acht minuten
gegen ultras mehr auf jeden fall also
das hat auch power so ein feuer unser
käse kommt drauf und unter
kontinuierlichem rühren gebe ich ihr
hinzu hört ihr das ist schon da ist noch
nicht mal der ganze käse drin
diese fünf familien
[Musik]
also werde dass das real mckenzies wenn
die hälfte von unserem käse schön
geschmolzen ist die mir das ganze wieder
auch die hitze und fügen jetzt 500
milliliter kondensmilch hinzu es gibt
auch die methode dass man das ganze in
milch koch wie wirkt aber das risiko
dass die milch verbrennt dass das alles
einfach nicht so wunderschön
funktioniert und das was jetzt gerade
auch diese fäden sind werden wir gleich
durch die milch die auch noch mal
rasieren schmilzt aufgenommen wird von
den nudeln das werden wir verlieren
so weil wir dafür jetzt nicht mehr ganz
so viel hitze haben wollen neben ihr
fuhr zu diesem korb hatten zur seite
abgeben einen stein in die mitte
so haben wir einfach nicht so eine
direkte hitze gruppe
der gesamte käse wurde jetzt nochmal
etappenweise hinein gegeben wie man das
ganze jetzt geschmolzen ist haben wir
unser ziel erreicht wir haben einen
mörder funktion mekies finde das ganze
jetzt noch wird ein wenig schwarzem
pfeffer
und sag mal so glaubt selbst wenn es
nicht schmecken würde jetzt wird es
schmecken nach dem man wirklich arbeit
reingesteckt hat das hier in rheydt so
zubereitet habe das ist schon was ganz
besonderes
stundenlange arbeit feuer braucht haben
wir schon wieder eigentlich
aber der rauch hat uns ein bisschen
abgefragt wird er konnte vielleicht auch
stellen weil sie nicht so viel sehen
aber was ihr sehen könnt und das zählt
sind diese ultra cremigen mccann cheese
also fragen dafür dass unser erstes mal
war dass sie so gekocht haben bin ich
sehr sehr stolz darauf ohne es
geschmeckt haben aber das wird ganz
besonders probieren wir
die verschiedenen aromen von den sechs
thesen das wirklich teilweise etwas
fruchtiges etwas herzhaftes diese
unsagbare cremigkeit das siehst du
wirklich ne was wir da gekommen ich
schwör's tier ist eine portion für zehn
leute 10 10 leute ich weiß nicht ob es
der wald ist ob es die arbeit ist oder
was auch immer das sind ich sagen so was
wir hoffen aber dass sich echt die
krassesten mac entschied sich hier
gegessen habe weil das will was heißen
wir haben in miami lobster mcinnis
gegessen für 60 70 dollar dass die idee
von kenji lopez und das ist auch einfach
genial was die stärke vom nudelwasser
die komplett drinnen benutzt
kondensmilch um schon so diese fülle der
milch zu haben ohne dass sie selbst
verkochen lassen muss aber es ist
einfach so genial weil es schmeckt so
gut du musst wirklich und die leute
müssen es hören deine reaktion muss man
dafür da von ihm einig was wir beim
nächsten seite was das heute noch den
kopf braucht sagt ich mag entries so
alle so abkratzen kommission um die ecke
bis zum schlüssel
probiert den spaß
ich aber sage immer feedback direkt aus
dem topf 4 dass der real deal dann kommt
nämlich komplett
er werde jeden fehler auch einzeln
probiert und speichert folgendes bringt
man nicht aber ich hätte niemals gedacht
dass sie so krass miteinander
harmonieren die textur perfekt oder die
nudeln perfekten bis weil wie du schon
sagst da waren ja käse dabei die völlig
unterschiedlich waren ich habe gerade
das war glaube ich dass wichtige das
ausbalancieren
also es war ein voller erfolg mehr als
richtig viel spaß gemacht wirklich mal
rauszukommen das zu machen ist ob eric
dir genau so war auch ultra anstrengend
aber das wichtigste wäre das natürlich
alles so wie wir es vorgefunden haben
löschen den ganzen spaß hier
wir beobachten jetzt dass das alles gut
vonstatten geht dann fahren wir auch
wieder nach hause dank an inszeniert für
die unterstützung ich weiß eine kleine
pause davon
so kann man arbeiten